Bonjour,
Pour le mois d'octobre, les autres créatrices
du tube et moi-même avions proposé le thème
d'Halloween en personnes originales que nous
sommes.
On est fin novembre, mais c'est pas grave,
c'est ça la liberté!
D'Halloween j'ai dévié vers les sorcières,
que j'ai déjà commencé à mentionner dans
ma vidéo sur l'Inquisition.
Si vous ne l'avez pas vue elle va apparaître
sur le canapé.
Voilà, vous pouvez cliquer.
Et les sorcières étant un sujet très large,
j'ai décidé de vous présenter une facette
des croyances les concernant: le sabbat.
Alors pour commencer, vous avez pu remarquer
que le mot sabbat est issu du shabbat, qui
est un rite religieux juif.
Ce n'est pas un hasard: à l'époque où
la peur des sorcières se répand et où les
premiers ouvrages de démonologie voient le
jour, vers le XIVe siècle, le judaïsme est
également mal considéré en France.
Dans certains ouvrages le sabbat est également
appelé «synagogue des sorcières»,
ce qui renforce son lien théorique avec le
judaïsme.
Le sabbat est une réunion nocturne entre
les sorcières et le diable avec qui elles
ont passé un pacte: en effet la croyance
admise est que le diable a été autorisé
par Dieu à tenter les humains et conclue
avec certains, surtout des femmes, des pactes
sataniques pour composer une société secrète
qui se réunit lors de sabbats et complote
à détruire l'ordre naturel des choses.
Le diable disposerait de plusieurs pouvoirs,
listés dans les ouvrages de démonologie
comme celui de Jean Tinctoris:
selon lui le diable peut faire apparaître
des serpents, commander la pluie, vent, tonnerres,
tempêtes, porter les gens en l'air et les
faire voler, ce qui est très intéressant
puisque d'après ces croyances ce ne sont
pas les sorcières qui volent, elles n'en
ont pas le pouvoir, mais c'est le diable qui
le leur permet.
Il peut également rompre les serrures, emporter
ce qui est dans les coffres et bien sûr tenter
les gens.
Par contre, il ne serait pas capable de transformer
un homme en bête.
On ne peut pas être bon partout.
De grands sabbats ont lieu à certaines dates
précises correspondant au rythme des saisons
et à la culture agraire: les solstices,
équinoxes, comme le 1er mai ou le 1er novembre.
Pour les autres sabbats, on n'est pas sûrs
des jours de la semaine choisis: plutôt
le mercredi et vendredi pour certains, mais
tous les auteurs ne sont pas d'accord.
Comment se déroule un bon sabbat concrètement?
Je tiens ici à rappeler, même si ça peut
sembler évident, que les descriptions qui
vont suivre nous montrent les croyances au
XVe-XVIe siècle, d'après les traités de
démonologie et les textes des procès de
sorcellerie.
D'abord la sorcière est chez elle, nue, et
s'enduit d'un onguent sur tout le corps avant
d'avaler une poudre à base de belladone.
Pourquoi, me direz-vous? Parce que c'est
de la DROGUE, à partir de là on peut donner
raison à tout et n'importe quoi.
Après avoir avalé sa dose elle prend son
envol sur un bâton ou un balai en passant
par sa cheminée.
L'antithèse du père Noël, en quelque sorte.
En volant, elle rejoint le lieu du sabbat
qui peut être dans une clairière, à un
carrefour...
En tout cas, dans un endroit désert, ou bien
un lieu où se trouveraient des pierres datant
de l'époque néolithique.
Comme ça, on garde un lien avec les religions
païennes.
Je reviendrai là dessus ensuite.
Il existe dans des tas de régions des lieux
où, selon les légendes locales, les sorcières
se rassemblaient pour le sabbat: le Bastberg
en Alsace, la lande de Carnac en Bretagne,
le sommet du Puy de Dôme en Auvergne ou Blakulla
en Suède...
Arrivées sur place, elles retrouvent une
foule très disparate, allant des nobles souvent
masqués à de petits enfants qui feraient
pâturer des crapauds.
Bonjour, Neville.
On entend un orchestre, selon les témoignages
discordant ou harmonieux, on s'échange des
recettes de potions et de sorts, puis la messe
est célébrée à rebours et présidée par
le diable en personne.
Pour communier, on prenait à la place de
l'hostie une rave noire.
Selon certains témoignages le diable prendrait
la forme d'un bouc; pour d'autres ce serait
un chat noir, dont les sorcières devraient
embrasser l'anus en arrivant au sabbat.
La bise.
Après la messe se déroulait un banquet de
mets soit délicieux, soit largement périmés:
là encore, les témoignages divergent.
En tout cas on ne consommait rien de salé,
et si vous connaissez les frères Winchester
vous comprendrez pourquoi: le sel et le
diable ne font pas bon ménage.
Ensuite c'est l'orgie, entre le diable et
les sorcières rassemblées, durant laquelle
elles lui confessent toutes les mauvaises
actions et les sorts qu'elles ont jetés.
Dans cette représentation inversée de la
justice divine, le diable récompense les
sorcières les plus mauvaises et punit celles
qui n'y sont pas allées assez fort ou qui
craignent encore trop l’Église.
On danse, aussi.
Beaucoup.
Toute la nuit.
Jusqu'au chant du coq, où soudain tout disparaît:
les sorcières se réveillent chez elle, où
elles reprennent leur vie jusqu'au sabbat
suivant...
Pour certains théologiens, ces sabbats n'ont
pas lieu dans notre monde mais en songe, et
la sorcière n'a jamais pris son envol sur
un balai pour se rendre au lieu du sabbat.
Ce sont simplement les drogues qu'elle avait
prises qui l'y ont emmenée.
Mais ça ne la désinculpe pas pour autant.
On peut voir dans l'imaginaire du sabbat une
référence aux bacchanales, des fêtes religieuses
gréco-romaines où l'on célébrait le dieu
Dionysos ou Bacchus pour les romains, et donc...
La picole.
La picole, la picole, la picole.
En effet le sabbat est une construction des
théologiens, dans laquelle ils réactivent
des stéréotypes anciens tels que les fêtes
païennes.
Les personnes qui avouent avoir participé
au sabbat sous la torture répondent aux questions
très précises des juges, ce sont ces derniers
qui fournissent les précisions démonologiques.
La sorcière commence par devoir raconter
l'initiation diabolique, concrétisée par
la marque et la copulation avec le diable,
puis le sabbat, et enfin la liste des torts
ou maléfices qu'elle a commis.
Dans certains pays comme le Danemark, il n'y
a pas de mythe du sabbat, malgré l'existence
de procès de sorcellerie.
Rares sont donc les historiens qui soutiennent
la réalité du sabbat, même si l'on en excluait
l'intervention du diable.
Alexandrian, dans son Histoire de la philosophie
occulte, dit cette phrase très évocatrice:
«Il n'y avait probablement pas de sabbat
dans cette région [pays basque] avant l'arrivée
de Lancre, conseiller au Parlement de Bordeaux,
tout au plus quatre fêtes saisonnières auxquelles
une fille lui confesse d'être allée.
Dès qu'il commence son office d'Inquisiteur,
il y en a un tous les lundis, puis toutes
les nuits; et peut-être que quelques-uns
ont été organisés réellement, par défi.»
Dans le sabbat, les théologiens font passer
tout ce qu'ils voudraient voir rejeté:
les activités nocturnes, les fêtes un peu
trop olé olé.
L'obscurité est le domaine du diable pour
les théologiens uniquement, alors qu'elle
est très animée et n'est pas toujours crainte
dans les campagne de l'époque.
Des bandes de jeunes célibataires s'y promènent,
boivent, font la fête...
Des démonologues ont pu croire y voir des
sabbats, ou avoir voulu interdire ces divertissements
de nuit par le biais des procès de sorcellerie.
Ainsi, peupler la nuit de démons et de sorcières
est une bonne manière de dissuader les célibataires
d'aller se promener.
A moins que ça ne leur donne des idées.
La prochaine fois on se retrouvera pour du
Chroniques de Prof, j'ai pas encore exactement
décidé du sujet mais j'ai quelques recherches
en cours.
D'ici là portez vous bien et continuez d'aimer
l'Histoire!
Aurevoir.